every downhill ski binding has a toe and
heel piece the toe usually releases
sideways in a fall and the heel releases
upward
today's bindings are made of lightweight
materials such as extruded aluminum and
fiberglass reinforced plastic using 3d
software the research and development
team designs the binding along with the
molds and dyes used to manufacture the
components the team produces a prototype
of each component and uses three
dimensional measuring tools to verify
the specifications workers paint the
visible aluminum and plastic components
then cure them in an oven for 40 minutes
this company produces high-end racing
models as well as less expensive models
for beginner to intermediate skiers this
aluminum housing is for the toe piece of
a racing binding they screw on plastic
tabs to keep the metal from damaging the
plastic ski boot then workers assemble
the indicator which is used to adjust
the release setting they lubricate the
ball joint with grease before putting
the base in an assembly fixture
then they add the toe piece housing and
a plastic cap with a white line on the
side as they screw down the cap it
compresses the spring underneath next
they mount a heel piece to a base and
assemble the internal mechanism this
includes a screw down cap that sets the
internal spring to a specific release
setting an automated machine test each
heel and toe piece to make sure the
mechanism functions correctly next a
metal pin connects the pivoting top of
the heel piece to the base this setting
tool locks the pin in its lateral
position now workers mount the ski break
to the heel piece the ski boot maintains
pressure on the break to keep it in the
off position in a ski accident the fall
releases that pressure triggering the
break after the binding has been
adjusted to the length of the ski boot
workers insert a notching pin that locks
the heel piece to the mounting plate of
the ski finally workers connect this
lever to the notching pin you simply
pull it up and back to disengage the pin
and adjust for boot length
provided the binding is correctly set
for the skiers weight boot size and
skiing ability these standards ensure
the ski boot releases in an accident but
doesn't inadvertently release if the
skier hits a big bump